an experienced head maker performs the
initial steps of making the head of the
paintbrush she unrolls and straightens
out a bundle of red sable then separates
enough hairs for one brush of this size
she inserts the hairs into a metal band
called a ferrule made of nickel-plated
brass she feels how they fit in the
ferrule if the fits too tight she
removes some hairs if it's too loose she
adds some brushes of different shapes
required different tensions the head
maker takes the correct brass mold for
the brush shape she's making and inserts
the hairs all the way down into the mold
cavity she ties the roots of the hairs
together with the string
then removes them from the mold she
inserts the brush head back into the
ferrule then removes the string she dips
the hairs into a solution of starch and
water and works the solution into all
the hairs by massaging the head on a
towel the starch allows the hairs to be
trained to a permanent shape she makes
this particular pointed shape by
spinning the head then smoothing the
hairs with her fingers the starch dries
overnight locking in the shape
to make the paintbrush handle a worker
in church birch dowels in a pegboard
then mounts the board upside down on a
dipping machine this machine submerges
the dowels in black lacquer paint
[Music]
after one day of drying time there's a
second two-part way this time and silver
paint
the machine has markings to indicate how
deep to dip the dowels for each color
[Music]
after another day of drying time there's
a third to this time partway in black
paint this creates a black handle with
the silver stripe
[Music]
once the last coat of black paint dries
a worker uses a pad printer to stamp
lettering on the handle with quick-dry
silver egg
a worker glues the brush head onto the
handle then the worker sets the brush
aside for a couple of hours until the
glue partially dries to a tacky state
because the next step
crimping would crack the fully dried
heart and flew the worker inserts the
ferrule into a crimping machine which
has been loaded with the die that's the
correct diameter for this brush handle
the machine crimps the ferrule tightly
to the handle attaching it permanently
once that glue hardens then a brush is
finally ready from this point onward
it's in the artists hands